Washington journal continues we're white
and welcome independent senator Bernie
Sanders every month good morning thanks
very much for being with us thank you
your single-payer plan how would it work
well what it does is begins to deal with
the major problems that exist in our
current health care system everybody I
think understands that our current
system is disintegrating we have 46
million people without any health
insurance we have more or underinsured
and at the end of the day we end up
spending despite those results far more
money per capita almost twice as much as
any other country and our health care
outcomes how we do an infant mortality
our longevity disease prevention is not
as good as many other countries now why
is that the reason to my mind largely
has to do with the fact that our system
is geared toward making money for the
private health insurance companies and I
don't want to shock any of the viewers
but the function of a private health
insurance company is not to provide
quality health care to all people in a
cost-effective way it is to make as much
money as they possibly can and when you
have that paradigm if that's what the
goal of the system is you end up not
only with 1,300 separate private health
insurance companies but you end up with
thousands of different benefit packages
which cost an enormous amount of money
to administer so the bottom line is we
are the most not only most expensive or
the most bureaucratic in wasteful system
in the world because we are spending
hundreds and hundreds of billions of
dollars in administration in
profiteering for the insurance companies
whose profits have been doing very very
well and giving exorbitant compensation
packages to CEOs a couple of years ago a
fellow who is the head of UnitedHealth
got 1.6 billion dollars in stock options
etc etc so the goal of health care
should be to provide the best quality
health care to all of our people in the
most cost effective way and to my mind
the way you do that and what we have
learned from other countries around the
world is that a single-payer system
would work let me read to you this is
from David grat sir he is a position
canada he had penned this editorial this
morning the wall street journal called
canada's obamacare precedent he also
talks about the situation in the United
Kingdom but he concludes with this
question quote why are they rushing into
a system of government dominated health
care when the very countries that have
experienced it for so long are backing
away well first of all I don't know that
that's accurate the truth of the matter
is we are the only country the only
country in the industrialized world not
to have the national health care program
so we are the odd guys out second of all
if you compare the American system to
Canada it is true Canada has problems so
do we but we spend almost twice as much
per person as the Canadians do and if we
spent that kind of money continue to
spend that kind of money 2.3 trillion
dollars eighteen percent of our gdp we
can have a better system than the
Canadians I think the correct question
to ask is how does it happen that every
other country major country on earth
says a healthcare is a right of all
people we don't do that and second of
all they end up coming up with a much
more cost-effective approach and three
their outcomes in many cases infant
mortality our life expectancy
preventable deaths are better than that
we do I I think the evidence is
overwhelming our current system is not
working and we have to move in a very
very different directions we have to
have the courage to take on the private
insurance companies who spend hundreds
of millions of dollars in lobbying
campaign contributions the drug
companies who charge us the highest
prices in the world and also have a very
powerful lobbying for us here in DC can
you clear something up because there's
been a lot of discussion in this town
over the single-payer plan and what
senator Baucus the chairman of the
Senate Finance Committee will in won't
put on the table is it on the table no
well what Baucus did is I arranged for a
meeting between a number of physicians
and nurse organizations with Baucus and
I think what he said is months ago he
said single payer is not on the table
and what he indicated to us that he
regretted saying that then he he should
have held a hearing you should have
listened to him and he apologized in a
sense but not but the truth of the
matter is in my view I speak only for
myself now the power of the insurance
companies who make so much money out of
our current health
system and the drug companies is just so
strong that it's very hard for us to get
the kind of hearing and the kind of
success that we need to move toward a
single-payer system say you're saying
special interests are influencing the
debate influencing the bait no I think
special interest own the debate I mean I
I don't want to shock you but in fact
these guys have spent hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
dollars to make sure we do not have a
cost-effective comprehensive universal
health care system but guarantees health
care to all people so what does that
tell the person out there that doesn't
have insurance in wondering what's going
to happen next well it tells them
there's a lot of debate and after I
leave this interview and a couple of
hours I'll be meeting with the help
committee health education labor
committee of which I'm remember we're
going to be talking about things and we
don't know what the end result will be
it is possible we will make some
progress in terms of primary health care
in terms of disease prevention in terms
of making health care more affordable to
people who today don't have any health
insurance but my concern is look is that
we're going to be pouring huge amounts
of money into a system which is largely
dysfunctional and that means it's like a
leaky bucket you keep pouring water into
it you can have some good success in
keeping water in the bucket you have to
keep putting more and more into it
rather than understanding why the system
is so wasteful and inefficient in
California my understanding is that
about one out of three health care
dollars goes not the doctors not to
nurses not the medicine not to making us
well or keeping us from getting sick it
goes to administration and that is
basically the crux of the problem right
now our system is designed to make money
for the drug companies and the insurance
companies not to provide quality health
care to all people and I think we've
gotta change direction in a very
substantive way one of the leading
debaters on the issue of health care is
the subject of peace this morning in the
Washington Post by Paul Kane on the cusp
of historic majority Senate Democrats
missed the pillars also a reference to
Senator Robert Byrd who's 91 years old
but Senator Kennedy who is battling
brain cancer and there's a quote from
your colleague Mitch McConnell in the
piece
it's hard to imagine a Senate without
them also a story this morning inside
the New York Times in a quote from
Senator Jack Reed of Rhode Island saying
that I think we would all like to see
senator Kennedy here for many many
reasons but we're going to move forward
forward without him will he be at all
part of this debate I don't know we
heard him he was part of a telephone
conference call a week ago and he
sounded good we're going to be meeting
today Mindless then he's probably not
going to be there and i think chris dodd
is kind of picking up leadership of the
committee the other point that I want to
make when we talk about health care it's
not just a personal issue with people
uninsured underinsured or paying close
to eight thousand dollars is what we're
paying per person right now which is
unsustainable it's an economic issue and
everyone's talking about General Motors
going bankrupt well General Motors today
spends more money per automobile on
health care than they do on steel and in
my state of Vermont and all over this
country small businesses just cannot
afford to put more money into escalating
health care costs when they would like
to reinvest in their business and create
jobs and make some money so we have as
the president appropriately points out
not just a crisis at the individual
level it is a major economic crisis that
we have got to address and that's why we
need real health care reform John
Webster who agrees with you is sending
in this tweet saying regrettably our
doctors and insurance companies are
thieves we need national health care
like other developed countries well let
me also say this you know the concept of
single-payer is not some fringy idea you
have 15,000 physicians in this country
15,000 who support a single-payer system
we have the largest nurses organizations
in this country that support single day
and you know why they are sick and tired
of being told what to do by the private
insurance companies those a study came
out a few weeks ago where doctors are
spending between two and three weeks
just arguing with insurance companies
about the kind of therapy that they can
prescribe nurses are doing the same
thing people go into medicine and they
go into nursing they want to practice
their profession they want to work with
people not screaming insurance companies
are and and
which which prevents them from doing
what they were trained to do senator
Bernie Sanders is our guest Junior is
joining us on the phone from Kansas City
good morning I few things I'd like to
talk about it if I could you know once
and she said I found out we found out
that that the kanga they have a ten-year
patent rights under medicine in America
we have a 20-year patent right why is it
that that our congress hasn't done
something about that to give these
pharmaceutical companies the right to
charge as much as they can for for
medicine for 20 years it takes away from
anything we could possibly do and then
the other thing is I haven't met you
that this became a chiropractor I was
talking to it his education is constable
better than a quarter of a million
dollars before he ever going to check it
to chest to work as a collar back let me
answer two questions I live an hour away
in Vermont from the Canadian border I
was the first member of the United
States Congress when I was in the house
to take Americans over the Canadian
border to purchase prescription drugs in
Montreal and I'll never forget as long
as I live the expression on the face of
women many of many of those who were
with me was struggling with breast
cancer and they bought a drug at that
point this is number of years ago called
tamoxifen which is used for breast
cancer they paid one-tenth the price
one-tenth the price in Canada for the
same exact medicine that they were
buying in the United States and I should
tell the caller that right now as many
of us are fighting for a program we call
re-employ tation of medicine so that
Americans do not continue to get ripped
off by the drug companies and have to
pay the highest prices in the world in
terms of Education again one of the
problems that we have is that many
people who graduate medical school today
are very very deeply in debt in the
University of Vermont Medical School for
example it's about 150,000 if you go to
dental schools even more what we are
trying to do and have
succeeded doing in the stimulus package
is greatly expand a program called the
National Health Service Corps which
provides debt forgiveness for those
doctors and dentists to work in
underserved medically underserved areas
we need to get more doctors out into the
areas where people need them for primary
health care more nurses out there more
dentists out there we are making some
success in that but we have a long way
to go but the cost of medical education
now is such that the average person
graduates 150 thousand dollars in debt
they're going to go to become a
specialist in order to make the kinds of
money they need to pay off that debt and
that's a real problem I guess Bernie
Sanders the former mayor of Burlington
former member of the House in his first
term than the US Senate Patrick is on
the phone from Atlanta good morning good
morning um 77 Sanders I just wanted to
thank you for your honesty and your
service you always talk on truth and you
always arm there's never any special
interest money around behind your
campaigns you always armed represent the
people and I'll just wanted to thank you
for your service sir um right my
question is what is it what are we going
to do against their insurance companies
when the bill is going through the
Congress and they try to strangle it the
same way be bidding on 94 with all
hillarycare well let's be clear what we
are right now off to get single-payer
for the moment to the best of my
knowledge there is no Republican not one
that wants a public plan a strong at the
very least a medicare plan for all
Americans and you have some conservative
Democrats who are also wavering on that
issue I think what we need is a dancer
Patrick's question just a very strong
grassroots movement which says that
health care in America must be a right
of all people that it doesn't make any
sense that a working person who may work
at a company that doesn't provide good
quality healthcare can go bankrupt if
they end up in the hospital well
somebody else has good care it doesn't
make any sense that we spend almost
twice as much as any other country on
healthcare healthcare has got to be a
human right for all people and we need
to mobilize in the same way patch
that we dealt with civil rights that was
a struggle that went on for decades that
we dealt with women's rights that we
dealt with other fundamental injustice
'as in America this is a civil rights
issue of our time it is wrong the
families are going bankrupt it is wrong
that families because they can't afford
healthcare it is wrong in my view that
millions of people we have 60 million
people in America today who do not have
a doctor of their own and we have almost
20,000 people who die every year from
diseases which were preventable because
they never went to the doctor that's
over six times every single year the
people we lost on 911 this is a moral
issue it is a civil rights issue and our
position must be health care for all
people quality health care regardless of
income and we can do that in my view by
if we take on the private insurance
companies and the drug companies without
spending any more than the amount of
money that we're spending today that's
the struggle we're in right now Andy
Rosenberg who is a democratic lobbyist
he works for Ogilvy government
associations and this piece is morning
from David Drucker in roll call he's
quoted as saying this a potential
challenge looms for the Washington
leadership of these trade associations
with reference to healthcare related
associations how do they maintain their
relationships and commitment to a
process and what happens if when the
details come out their membership is not
convinced that the process is worth
participating in don't get it when he's
talking about the role of lobbyists in
this whole process well I'm not sitting
around here worrying about lobbyists I
mean lobbyists of the bloody problem
whenever you take on getting back to the
question about prescription drugs we pay
by far the highest prices in the world
for prescription drugs the
pharmaceutical industry over a period of
years has spent hundreds of millions of
dollars lobbying Congress huge amounts
of money of campaign contributions
advertising they never lose they have
never ever lost in a battle with
Congress so I don't sit around worrying
about the lobbying I have too many
lobbyists here and then leave form
leaders of the Republican Party
Democratic Party's guys making hundreds
of thousands of dollars a year
representing big money interests I think
maybe we need a little bit more energy
for ordinary people for the middle class
for working people so when this goes
along your lines because the essence is
desaree from David Drucker is that
publican allies are mounting a public
relations offensive to put the brakes on
President Obama's overall health care
question their job is to represent the
insurance companies to make sure that
CEOs can make tens of millions of
dollars a year that companies are very
very profitable and they could care less
that millions of Americans are paying
far more than they can afford we have
we're spending about seventy eight
hundred dollars per person on health
care can you imagine it what is a family
that makes thirty thousand dollars a
year do you can't afford that anyway and
it's going up and up and up 46 million
without any health insurance and these
guys are worried about the profits of
the insurance companies that is just an
outrage and we have to have the courage
to stand up to them from the Republican
line Eddie is on the phone from Savannah
Georgia good morning good morning good
morning senator Sanders come on again um
the information of the the conversation
that you haven't majority of it is true
the previous representatives from
Georgia was not telling the truth as it
relates to of the insurance information
I have three insurance policies 1 i'm a
retiree and one is through my job which
are contribute one is through my husband
which he pays nothing and that is
because his was through a union and he
pays up three phases union dues and what
have you and the other is medicare i am
still paying through the nose for my
share of health coverage i have two
types of drug coverage one through my my
own personal to my retirement plan that
i had but you know before and went
through my husband i have a chronic
illness of and with my drug company i
pay ten dollars no $20 20 something
dollars through my husband the same
medication costs me to him
and you know they are in cahoots well I
mean I think here's the point health
care is expensive any system in the
world is expensive but it makes no sense
for us to be spending an estimated 350
or 400 billion dollars a year in
wasteful administrative costs we have an
enormously complicated system the all of
us will remember during the campaign I
happen to think it's one of the reasons
that barack obama won the election he
was talking about his mother who was
dying of cancer trying to summon up her
energy to be strong having to fight with
the insurance company for coverage and
all over America that is what is going
on he is a story in the last 30 years we
have seen 25 times more jobs created for
healthcare bureaucrats who argue with us
about whether or not we're covered that
we have seen in the increase of
physicians we need more doctors
especially primary care we need more
dentists we need more nurses we're not
getting that you know what we are paying
for through the nose we're paying for
healthcare bureaucrats who are out there
arguing with us about whether or not
we're coming we have an enormously
complicated system so the way you save
money is to come up with a simple system
frankly no system is perfect but at the
end of the day you say you don't want
you're an American you're going to have
all of the health care that you need
it's going to be paid for out of the
public system it's going to be paid for
out of taxes you're not going to be
paying product at health insurance
you're not going to be having 16
different programs there everybody is
going to get the same quality health
care and if we move in that direction we
save hundreds of billions of dollars in
administration we put that into coverage
for all Americans and I think we have
the best system in the world Jim had
said in this tweet senator Sanders why
not propose a bill to ban insurance
companies that seems to be your goal to
put them out of business it is my goal
and we have introduced that legislation
it's called the single Pam garrison is
next from the state of Wisconsin good
morning good morning senator thank you
very much for the fight you're putting
on I am 70 years old retired and have
just
had three major surgeries two heart
surgeries and prostate cancer surgery my
wife has been forced out of having
health insurance and we are at the brink
of bankruptcy I fought very hard to get
President Obama elected and I am become
very bitter and very disillusioned when
you have somebody like Senator Baucus
who won't give a singer payer
single-payer people a seat at the table
and he's taking hundreds of thousands of
dollars in contributions front from the
people that are creating the situation
we have in this country I would very
much like to see a bill passed if it's
possible that no one in Congress takes a
dime from these people not one dime they
are ruining our country they could care
less about anything that has to do with
what's good for the people of this
country you've raised the very very
important issue and it has to do not
just with health care not just with the
cost of prescription drugs not with the
deregulation of Wall Street's those
crooks could lead us into a major
recession what we're talking about is
the impact that big money has on the
political process in Washington and I
think the caller is absolutely right it
is an extremely negative impact and in
my view that is why we have to move to a
public funding of elections candidates
and incumbent members should not be
dependent on big money interest because
I'm afraid that dependence leads
legislation which does not work for
ordinary people the gentleman talked
about bankruptcies and here's an
interesting point ah in 2007 sixty-two
percent of bankruptcies personal
bankruptcies in this country were
related to medical bills sixty-two
percent and the majority of those people
had health insurance so even if in many
cases you have health insurance if you
have large deductibles if your insurance
policy doesn't cover
of your needs you can go bankrupt and
large numbers of people are doing that
John had emailed this question currently
healthcare is a regulatory and
bureaucratic mess how would government
make this any better how would a
single-payer system in all the corporate
cronyism that comes with it help look
nothing is perfect but this is what we
got so far you got a veteran's
administration doesn't have its problems
sure it does but I'm on the Veterans
Committee what I can tell you is
veterans throughout this country by and
large a very supportive of the VA system
which is run far more cost-effectively
by the way the most other a hospital in
medical programs you have Medicare the
does Medicare have problems it sure does
but the administrative costs of Medicare
are a fraction of what private health
insurance costs are it runs more
smoothly I think the goal that we have
is to create a simplified system because
the complexity of the current system has
to do with insurance companies among
other things cherry picking saying we
want to cover you because you've just
run the marathon and you're 20 years of
Asia we're quite sure that you're not
going to get sick you're a good guy to
cover on the other hand if you are 50
years of age and had a cancer operation
we really don't want to cover you at all
because we're going to lose money on you
and it becomes a very complicated a
process or to cover you not cover them
but we have got to say as a nation we're
all in this together we're all going to
get coverage and we're going to do that
delivery system in the most
cost-effective way we're going to put
more money into disease prevention we're
going to put more money into primary
care 60 million Americans today twenty
percent of our country if you can
believe it do not have access to a
doctor on a regular basis what happens
to those people when they get sick they
either go to the emergency room at very
expensive care whether they get sick and
they end up in the hospital at
outrageously expensive care the nature
of private insurance is not to address
those needs because many of those people
don't have a whole lot of money so we
need a simplified system we need a
universal system we need a comprehensive
system I believe we can do that will
senator Baucus hold a hearing on the
single-payer system I what he indicated
to the people
I met with him is that he apologized he
thought he should have done that he
thought wasn't a hundred percent sure
that at this stage in the process
probably too late for the Finance
Committee on the other hand i'm on the
health education committee which is the
other committee dealing with this issue
i believe we will have a testimony to
the best of my knowledge from single
payer advocates but who is leading the
effort with Senator Kennedy battling
cancer who is the point person on health
care right senator Dodd is the is at
this moment I think taking most of the
along with other centers we are meeting
our as i mentioned later on this morning
we're going to be going on for three or
four hours just going down the bills so
up a dot i think has assumed the
leadership in senator baucus open to
your ideas insert he's not to a
single-payer idea not in a million years
does that bother you well it bothers me
it's not just senator baucus it is verte
every Republican I mean let's be clear
is a Democrat if I'm an independent and
that's why I'm [ __ ] you caucus with the
death I causes you know look what am I
gonna sit here and tell you Democrats
are perfect they are immune from money
pressure Christina we have some
wonderful Democrats what fighting to do
the right thing but you have some
conservative Democrats who will be
working with three Republicans now from
a political point of view let me say
this there is some people say well we've
got to move forward in a bipartisan
approach which means that we have to
have cloture on a filibuster which means
you need 60 votes which means that you
have to make major major compromises my
guesses of you and I may be wrong in
this but my strong feeling is if we end
up with a bill that has 60 or 70 votes
it would be such a weak bill that will
not accomplish I think what the American
people want I would rather pass a strong
bill with 51 votes than a week bill with
65 or 70 votes bottom line is the
current system is dysfunctional we're
wasting 300 400 billion dollars are and
we need to move toward a cost-effective
comprehensive universal program we have
to finally move in that direction this
is a human right and we have to have the
courage to take on the drug companies
and the insurance companies so just
exert enormous power here in Washington
karen is Republican joining us from
grading her Iowa good morning Karen
good morning I have a quick statement
and another question certainly the
biggest problem we have in America is
greed and it goes all the way from the
largest politician all the way down to
the individual that's what I believe and
no matter what system is put in place
there agree will always find a loophole
and because people aren't honest and
people don't care about other people
that's the problem I raise kids on 1500
a month never went bankrupt never had
defaulted on a loan and never had health
insurance my ex-husband wouldn't pay for
it and I couldn't afford it but you know
what I paid my bills and I didn't buy
brand-new cars and that's how I did it
so it is doable for the individual but
my question is is what about putting a
cap on how much these how much these are
big CEOs can make and all different
things and also as far as uh I'm looking
for a politician who is willing you know
people fought and died for this country
we don't even have a politician who is
willing to sacrifice his job let me
start off with the first point that
Karen made she's right I mean we are in
a moment in history and we saw this from
the people on Wall Street who were not
content with making thirty or forty
percent rates of return they had to make
more not content as hedge fund managers
with making a billion dollars in
personal game they apparently needed to
make much is right and greed permeates
almost every aspect powerful life but I
would say to Karen who is as I
understand it living with no health
insurance because she don't have a whole
lot of money Karen that's a dangerous
position to be in because you never
never know what's going to happen
tomorrow you don't know what kind of
illness can develop you don't know what
kind of accident your kid could happen
can have so I think as a nation we have
got to move toward health care for all
people in terms of putting one's job on
the line I think there are people in
Congress perhaps a minority who are
prepared to stand up to the big money
interest and and take on the drug
companies and the insurance companies
but i think karen is right in the
sensitive that's just not enough we have
a call an email and a tweet
this tweet from Daniel yanked who says
my sister had cancer and went bankrupt
because of it ten years later she's had
problem getting jobs because she had
cancer well this is another issue a
bankruptcy we touched on the ID you know
if you go to other countries around the
world and people are going to criticize
all the countries but you asked how many
people go bankrupt because of illness in
Canada or in other countries the answer
in most cases is 0 it just doesn't
happen and second of all we have
millions of people today who are staying
on their jobs you know where to stay on
their jobs because they wanna stay on
their jobs that because the content or
have begun to charge because they have
decent health insurance and they're
afraid to leave their jobs to go to
another job where the health insurance
is not as good does that make any sense
from a personal point of view or from an
economic point of view and the answer is
it doesn't so what we have got to do is
move away from employer-based health
care to national health care which says
if you are an American no matter what
your job is you can be sweeping the
streets you can be the president of the
United States you're gonna have the same
quality comprehensive health care this
viewer from San Antonio saying would you
please clarify with senator Sanders at
the federal health care policy that they
receive referring to members of Congress
is seriously subsidized by tax dollars
unlike the comments of congressman
Gingrey who's you know joined each
other's right his run for two things
about that number one the program that I
have as a center is the best of my
knowledge the same as postal workers the
same as my secretary the same as anybody
who works for the federal government so
it's not like members of Congress others
different policy our second of all the
caller is right like many other
employer-based health care system our
health care system the federal health
care system is of course subsidized by
the government absolutely right sandy
our last call from Casper Wyoming
independent line for independent senator
Bernie Sanders good morning good morning
I just wanted to talk about and you know
i'm not sure that national health care
is the answer i know we need something i
am a retired social worker I just
retired the loads less than a year ago
20 years in Social Work can
nursing-homes hospital assisted living
worked with Medicare Medicaid in the VA
system it's terrible people have a
terrible time with it and the nursing
homes the doctors offices have to employ
two three four people to try and get
reimbursement for Medicare to argue with
Medicare and Medicaid on their bills I
just I worried that a national health
care system run by the government like
Medicare Medicaid is going to be another
problem like that I think I saw my
doctor recently my heart doctor I saw
him for ten minutes it cost me $92 that
is part of the problem with health care
that's outrageous can I take Sandy's
point and move it ahead to one final
question you can respond to her
situation but also ultimately what you
think Congress is going to vote on but
what I would say to sandy is I think if
you talk to most physicians they will
tell you the dealing with the private
insurance companies is a lot worse than
dealing with the VA or the Medicare is
my understanding ah and in terms of
Sandy paying $92 she's doing pretty well
I have heard horror stories where people
walk into an emergency room for an hour
so they come out with a thousand-dollar
bill uh and that deals with
reimbursement rates among other things I
think we in many ways are not putting
enough money into primary health care
too many doctors are going into
specialty care and that confluence of
doctors and specialty care in many ways
is driving up costing is an issue that
we're looking at now what's going to
happen I don't I don't see a crystal
ball d i'm not i think the situation
today is is significantly in flux I
think you got two committees in the
Senate working on it you got two
committees in the house worth noting if
the president who is going to intervene
so I think we don't know at this point
what's going to happen but I would
conclude by saying I hope that the
American people get actively involved in
this process and i hope that they will
demand that health care in America
become a human right that all of us have
it regardless of income
and that we have a simple comprehensive
high quality system the guarantees
health care to all people senator Bernie
Sanders of Vermont you're always
gracious with your time